t le festival d'avignon et la cour
d'honneur du palais des papes s'apprête
à accueillir l'événement pour la
première fois isabelle huppert va en
effet se produire sur ce plateau
mythique
elle a choisi d'incarner médée
d'euripide sous la direction de jacques
lassalle une tragédie grecque et un rôle
difficile puisque cette femme en arrive
à l'infanticide par dépit amoureux
dominique pensec jean-marc l'allier
ce qui gronde actrice de cinéma veut
aussi devenir absolument elle l'a déjà
montré une vraie actrice de théâtre
c'est ça c'est un alliage très précieux
mais très rares d'extrême intelligent
d'extrême détermination d'extrême
exigences et extrême modestie artisanes
je vais assassiner les enfants que j'ai
fait la cour d'honneur du palais des
papes
il avait lu père en rêvait depuis le
conservatoire ailier donc enfin pour
incarner la plus mythique des mères
infanticides gracile et pâle dans sa
robe de satin blanc elle va donc être
cette femme qui va commettre line mal
parce qu'elles sont trop d'être trop mal
aimé les soulage la paix
quand elle entre en scène d'emblée en
est saisi par la légalité et la
souveraineté de son job douloureuse par
l'ama de ses propres enfants
je suis prêt mais toute la maison et les
mid et à cela d'autres avouent leur eau
le pire des hommes et qui m'a trahi
j'avais envie de jouer mais dès qu'ils
qui est peut-être là la première grande
criminelle meurtrière en face le grand
personnage féminin qui fait qui fait
l'expérience du mal de la de la pulsion
monstrueuse
il ya dans l'être humain si cette fille
prend la parure et en couvre sa peau
elle nous la demeure affreuse
enfin je n'étais pas à l'idée qu'on se
fait généralement de là
la grande tragédienne classique et en
même temps je j'utilise c'est ça c'est à
dire que je je rends compte à travers
l'idée de ce qu'elle peut avoir des plus
banales ce sera tant supplice ils me
dégoûtent la source la plus grande n'est
parfois de l'apparence cas plus frêle
demain soir isabelle huppert devrait
être entré dans la légende avignonnaise